my son i asked him recently here hey man
so you got any um
any stories i don't know about
i'm looking for some new jokes
and he said
i won't get in trouble
i don't know you man you're not going to
get trouble he goes okay oh okay
okay oh okay oh okay uh
so at this point i have like all these
memories rushing through my head oh did
i ever tell you that time
when you and mom were out of town
and i had some friends over and we all
did acid i said [ __ ] no
surprise
how do you guys do you want to hear
about that time i go yeah that's the
exact time i do want to hear about
and he goes okay okay it was my senior
year
and it was me and probably three or four
friends and we all decided that we were
gonna do acid because i had the house to
myself and it was for the weekend and it
was a friday night and so we had a day
the next day to just chill out and be
good and he goes okay okay all i'm gonna
tell you is this
when i woke up the next morning
the pizza guy was still here
[Applause]
i woke up and there was a grown man who
i didn't know
in my living room not only did the pizza
guy sleep at my parents house but he
also quit his job so he could drink some
beers with some high school kids
probably not the greatest career move
that means that dude walked into the
party was like hey [ __ ] this eight
dollar an hour job
i'll find another one of these tomorrow
i'm getting [ __ ] up tonight i mean
once again thank you guys for stopping
by uh this story was just one of many
i'm gonna try and like pull some out of
the vault so i can start telling some
more stories and and hopefully i give
you guys a little bit more of a taste
about how it was growing up uh or what i
did growing up or you know what i did
for fun or just some dumb [ __ ] you know
um but you know as always please leave a
like leave a comment hit the
notification button so you know when we
drop new stuff and uh most of all please
please please hit that subscribe button
it uh it means the world to us it costs
nothing to you to click a button so uh
thank you guys again for stopping by
don't forget hey man podcast is out we
got a bunch of episodes already up new
one every week um and the outpouring
amount of support and love that we've
been getting from that has been amazing
uh and so from my dad and i can
definitely say thank you guys so much
and make sure you guys go check out a
new episode all right y'all have a good
one
you